let's let's watch plastic recycling as
an actual scam because I've heard about
this before boy I got a lot of plastic
here and don't worry I'm going to be
putting it in a recycling bin because
I'm not a sociopath or some kind of
libertarian but here's the thing most of
this plastic will end up in a landfill
or burned or in the ocean and that's
because most plastic is not recyclable
oh but it's got the recycling symbol
right on it
this is the recycling symbol created in
1970 and this is a resin identification
code created by the Plastics industry in
1988 to trick people into thinking
plastic was recyclable and therefore may
be okay for the environment wow
recycling is a lie not crazy a little
more plastic I'm Raleigh Williams
climate science grad student wow now I
wonder how many people in Congress make
money off of the Plastics industry that
they let that fly over here they go in
climate climate climate and over here
they're letting one of the most major
industries on Earth and you so slide
with that with that chicory so when
plastic first became a thing since it's
such like a usable and sturdy material
people were reusing it so what these big
companies did is they they took a lot of
time focused on media and they were like
why reuse your plastic just you know buy
new stuff it's so cheap anyways don't
reuse the same old dirty plastic so
because that way they would get you know
more sales and stuff and since it's so
cheap to produce the margins are so big
and then later on as usual and people
realized how bad it was for the
environment they came up with recycling
to make people feel better I didn't know
didn't know that isn't that crazy though
it makes perfect sense just so that
people can continue buying plastic they
make more money and people think they're
doing a good thing it doesn't make sense
to he's going to get into it and I hate
to say this but plastic recycling is an
actual scam
welcome to climate Okay so we have these
separate pickups separate containers
separate entire people on payrolls all
this stuff Millions hundreds of millions
of dollars spent in any any top 20
American city every year on these
programs and very little is actually
being recited it's not even it's cheaper
to just make new plastic than to recycle
the plastic it's literally cheaper so
these people on the top do you think
they really care about the environment
no no of course they don't like the
beginning of the plastic recycling is a
scam story starts with World War II uh
do I have your attention now everybody's
dad anyway the beginning of the most
camera ready war in history the US
government felt that a flexible
lightweight material might really help
our boys give the Jerry's the old piss
and vinegar so the government forced
early Plastics companies to work
together to crank out plastic and to
have little slumber parties where they
shared their plastic Making Secrets and
the modern Plastic industry was born
since plastic is made out of oil and
natural gas plastic companies sprang out
out of existing fossil fuel corporations
and their hot cousins of the chemical
industry and the nightmare Lobby
Industry Group the Society of the
Plastics industry was born and I'm
pretty sure that's the last we'll be
hearing of them in this video about how
the Plastic industry scammed America
anyway it was their job to get the
American Consumer a group of people who
had never really bought plastic to start
buying a ton of plastic lucky for them
plastic kicks ass
plastic was lightweight cheap it
performed better than other substances
and it had the ungodly power of the
possible industry behind it basically
Plastics blew through America like
measles at an anti-vaxxer water park but
when Americans were saving their plastic
to reuse it Lobby groups just bought
advertisements telling them throw it out
every time we'll just make more plastic
out of our unlimited consequence free
supply of fossil fuels and that's when
Plastics came up against their first big
hurdle
on April 22nd one in every 10 Americans
took part in the public outcry on that
first Earth Day Led to political action
well that actually wasn't going to work
for the Plastics industry but they had a
compromise they felt would work for
everybody they'd lie so the Plastics
industry fossil fuel corporations and a
number of other companies formed a front
group called keep America beautiful they
got an Italian guy dressed him up like a
Native American stereotype do you
remember this dude
the crying India and he cries yeah that
was like a thing that you'd see yes no
it was and I don't care that they had an
actor play an American Indian I mean I'm
sorry I'm not I'm not into that world
[ __ ] it's called acting so that's
not an issue but the fact that this
whole industry is a bunch of horseshit
is definitely an issue I mean you know
though it's Americans it's our own fault
again you hear me complain all the time
people just order and [ __ ] order and
[ __ ] from overseas plastic junk go to
the store go to Walmart Christmas Tree
Shop Target it's all loaded with just
plastic [ __ ] that was shipped from the
other side of the earth oh yeah uh you
don't need it you don't need it some
people have a deep
[Music]
there was a huge anti-littering of um I
push when I was a kid too because people
were just animals and they still are I
mean you go to certain neighborhoods and
you just I've been driving and just see
people like finish a bag of chips and
just drop it like dirt bags yeah it's
not crazy no people do that and they
started giving out tickets and it became
more you know people adopted it most
people adopted a you know classier way
of living and not just throwing their
trash out on the street or on the beach
or the park the crying Indian did help
with that there's five holy [ __ ] that's
crazy the Great Pacific Garbage Patch
it's just like a big river of trash in
the ocean
I mean yes sure they could have just
easily made their products less
disposable but why do that when you can
just spend a few million dollars on an
advertisement to convince you it's your
fault there's more trash everywhere not
crazy and it worked for a while see the
old depressed Italian maneuver got
people to start throwing their trash in
trash cans and even started some
Regional recycling programs but when a
louder call to end single-use items like
plastic cropped up in 1987 the Plastics
industry decided it was time to take
another trip to scamville where they
were pleasantly surprised to find they
were already the mayor okay do you
remember the Society of the Plastics
industry oh my God they're back
well anyway they genuinely did want
recycling to work so they looked into it
in the 1980s and discovered to their
horror that plastic can't really be
recycled the same chemical properties
that make it moldable and flexible also
make it degrade after one or two uses I
mean that's not a recycle that's a
re-loopty loop but even worse than any
of that recycling is expensive and labor
intensive and making new plastic from
fossil fuels is almost always cheaper
forever and maybe he'll get into this
but is I believe that glass and paper
are both highly recyclable and reusable
I could maybe I've been tricked on those
too I mean I'm sure I'm sure glosses you
just we use you reuse glass at home you
know I save I save glass jars and you
use them for storage you use them for
years yeah glass is definitely
recyclable unless a mistaken you can
melt it down and then turn it into
something else but plastic like it loses
its plastic plasticity the more you use
it there's it it loses its yeah it's
structural integrity
mechanisms for mixed plastic and that
they're a serious doubt that it can ever
be made viable on an economic basis
there was never an enthusiastic belief
Society
recycling was ultimately going to work
in a significant way I think they knew
that the infrastructure wasn't there
to really have recycling amount to a
whole lot but even though they knew
recycling had zero chance of stopping
plastic from just [ __ ] the world they
knew that if they could get people to
believe recycling worked they might have
a chance of stopping an actual plastic
bag he's he's saying though that they so
this is where am I going to you know
antennas go up that I start to question
things he's saying that they knew that
it was going to [ __ ] the world but I I
what did they really know you know they
knew that they were lying to people that
recycling actually works and that
they're just going to fill it up in
landfill it that they were going to fill
up in landfills and you know they I
don't know if they really understood the
the damage the environmental damage that
could be done and didn't care I don't
know I I I'm curious or if they just you
know thought it's not that bad and
there's no real damage coming from this
but let's just shut these little
lunatics over here up what was it he's
saying that they knew that it was
actually damaging to the to the planet
if the public thinks the recycling is
where working
then they're not going to be as
concerned about the environment that's
so true check out the old Society of the
Plastics industry had a plan While most
plastic could never be recycled
technically some plastic could be
recycled
so in 1988 they created a front group
called the council for Solid Waste
Solutions and they quietly lobbied
nearly 40 states to pass legislation
that required a symbol they created be
printed on every single piece of plastic
produced in America enter the resin
identification code officially just a
way to say I feel so it has to be
betrayed and tricked isn't that insane I
feel so stupid again like I see that and
I'm like okay and I've actually thought
of held stuff in my hand I'm like wow I
didn't know this is recyclable thinking
that they made advances and they got you
know they got savvier with the recycling
instead I was just being tricked [ __ ]
[ __ ] wow isn't that crazy and the
way that they purposely made it look the
same way just to trick people it's great
it's insane I love watching the curtain
come up I love it and so every issue you
could possibly think of cycling YouTube
is see the recycling we are raising the
curtain people are coming out and saying
we've been duped I love it just a way to
say what type of plastic item is made
out of now to be clear this is not a
recycling symbol it's either recycling
symbol was public domain as of 1970. so
the Plastics industry just kind of
borrowed it stuck a number inside and
now it's a completely different symbol
what do you mean it looks like the
recycling symbol don't you see the
number inside of the seven kinds of rics
only I was gonna say I was gonna say
have you guessed look how many aren't
recyclable and twos are commonly taken
and even they have a slim chance of
actually being recycled but the Plastics
industry has made sure that every single
piece of plastic has a recycle symbol on
it except no they didn't because that's
not a recycle symbol it's a resin
identification code because it's got it
okay I feel also very validated so years
ago I heard that less than 10 percent of
the stuff that we send to recycling
including glass and everything gets
recycled I don't it was just a number I
heard I can't remember uh exactly I
think it was on a date line episode or
something and I I stopped Recycling and
I just thought you know what this is
such a this is such horseshit they want
us to buy separate plastic bags and have
a separate container and do all this
work and waste all this water to rinse
things out before I put them in my
separate container so it doesn't smell
by the end of the week like I was like
this is there's no way this is good for
the environment that was just my
instinct and you know I don't recycle at
home I don't I just don't but what I do
is I reuse everything and I buy things
in glass jars and I put them through the
dishwasher after they're emptied and I
use them for storing nuts and rice and
the salsa jars that come in the ball
jars we use them to drink out of at home
so I I feel like I've actually been
doing more good by doing it my way well
I'm glad I stopped buying this [ __ ]
I just didn't know how deep it was the
trickery I feel really even I know it's
it's [ __ ] insane like thanks to
recycling is working
then they're not going to be as
concerned about the environment so
whenever these yes
the Plastic industry and fossil fuels
would just pour millions of dollars into
recycling campaigns until calls for
plastic reduction died out then they
just pull their funding and all the
recycling initiatives collapse until
it's time to promote recycling again
[Music]
for all the millions of dollars spent
touting the wonders of recycling only 10
percent has ever been recycled well damn
what are we gonna do well first of all
we gotta stop treating recycle like it's
the Beyonce in the Destiny's Child of
reduced reuse recycle Beyonce is reduced
reused and recycle is the other two
second we gotta keep Recycling and I
know I know I just spent like eight
minutes on recycling but recyclers are
the only people keeping that number at
10 and not zero percent in fact any
percent of a massive amount of plastic
is still significant and finally we have
to stop thinking about this like it's a
problem we can solve with a quiet little
choice at the grocery store legislation
got us into this problem legislation's
got to get us out we got to pressure our
governments to pass a ban on single-use
Plastics how bad is the problem oh great
question the plastic Lobby has plastic
that's mine
that's mine actually passed legislation
preemptively banning plastic bans that's
right it's a band ban and it's going to
murder murder our planet planet if we
can't get a hold of our legal system
it's going to take a group of people
working together so please
be one of those people in the
description of this video is a list of
all the active plastic legislation and
the groups behind it what's the what's
the alternative though so we can say
plastic bad we have to stop using it but
what are the Alternatives they it's not
an option go into any hospital and
everything that you need for sanitary
medical care hospitals dentists you know
Child Care Centers food preparation
where you have to wear gloves I mean we
need this for to stay alive and healthy
at this point and if you're not going to
come up with a real solid alternative on
how to how to get these things done then
you know this is all just more [ __ ]
crying yeah I guess reducing and reusing
is what's important if everyone just
stop buying as much plastic and you know
reuse [ __ ] except syringes use new
syringes don't worry about the landfill
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]